hoy ha salido un día soleado aquino de
esa y mucha gente ha decidido
simplemente salir a pasear o a tomar un
café oa mirar libros aquí en el mercado
del libro uno de los más famosos de la
ciudad para intentar un poco
despejarse de esta situación de guerra
aunque en esta ciudad hasta el momento
se vive una tensa calma donde los
negocios intentan seguir con la
normalidad algunos abren otros están
cerrados quien viene esta misma calle
hemos encontrado a david un franco
español que tiene una panadería francesa
y nos va a explicar cómo se están
viviendo estos días y sobre todo porque
ha decidido quedarse aquí hola bueno
estos días se vive en difícil porque no
hace falta de muchas cosas y para la
pregunta porque me he decidido de
quedarme aquí es porque he hecho mi vida
aquí me han recibido con mucho amor y
mucho corazón así que he decidió de
quedarme
y distribuir gratuitamente lo que tengo
café croissant todo lo que es panadería
estoy trata es una forma para mí de
ayudar a los ucraniano en este tiempo
difícil y bueno es fácil encontrar
suministros es fácil seguir manteniendo
el negocio abierto no no en nada del
suministro ya no tengo casi nada pero he
hecho alguna llamada en francia para
tener un camión lleno de mercancía
congelada decoración de estas compañías
me han prometido de mandarme eeuu la
semana que viene así que lo estoy
esperando porque de verdad que no tengo
más nada